pero aquí lo que llama la atención es
una posible derogación de la gp lo que
terminaría haciendo una estocada final
para el acuerdo de paz cual cree que es
el objetivo de esta propuesta
bueno yo pienso que esta propuesta es el
temor que tiene el propio expresidente
es senador uribe frente al tema de la
verdad el centro democrático ha hecho un
ataque visceral a todo el sistema
integral tanto a la justicia especial de
paz como a la comisión de la verdad como
la unidad de búsqueda yo creo que esa
propuesta es el temor que tiene esta
clase política que se sabe responsable
de los crímenes que han ocurrido durante
el conflicto armado en colombia